my name is Aviv Friedman and I'm going
to be lecturing tonight about some one
of the greatest players of the game I
think that he's somewhat I would say
unrecognized or underrated
underestimated but somehow when I grew
up I knew many games of course of
morphine will see something by Morphy
today and and all the legends of chests
Lasker Rubinstein Capablanca and before
then there was a European play by name
of odd of Anderson how many of you have
heard of him before probably some of you
all of you okay
maybe you'll be disappointed because
when he recognized the games that I'm
about to show you but you may recognize
one but probably not all three and he
was I think the best player in Europe
and at one point when Paul Morphy was so
good in the United States he was beating
everybody not only in Simon's and in
blindfolds and exhibitions but also in
regular matches over the board they
decided that he might you know play him
and well it was a little unpleasant what
happened there but to add the fun
descent but you will see an example of
that today
so you'll see two wins by Anderson and
one very bad loss this is one of his
famous games and it was very well known
at the chest wall does the Evergreen
game anybody saw it before some of you
saw before reading okay
but was it a class didn't see it should
I skip to something else or should we
still see it still see it okay all right
so he's playing the game is Anderson and
his opponent is de France he 45:9 f3
knight c6 Bishop c4 Bishop c5 of course
during the 19th century the Romantic era
this was just almost a copy a position
like a normal position you couldn't see
royal Lopez or hardly yeah you couldn't
see other thing this you could see it
but I mean this was definitely then that
dominant structure and an opening and of
course very typical to someone like
Anderson who was an extreme being an
extremely aggressive player before and
the Evans gambit okay so
he accepts c3 again a very typical move
of the gambit the idea is to quickly
control the center Bishop a5 okay
nowadays we know that there are the
moves like for example Bishop c5 Bishop
e7 are very well known but this is also
acceptable pawn to d4 takes castles
again a very mean position in the Evans
gambit has arisen and here black can
make several choices I have to tell you
that initially when I saw the move back
when I thought it was a bad move but
then I with time I realize it can't be
that bad because later on Kasparov
played it so there's nothing as Kasparov
doesn't play bad stuff never ever so not
even when he doesn't intend to or he
doesn't enter so d3 a kind of a strange
move ok nowadays most arguments are
about the move Knight G e7 is the main
line and why try different things like
Knight g5 for example and rook e1 all
kind of C takes d4 of course the main
move so in any event we're not here to
talk about the theory but rather enjoy
Anderson's performance you will see that
the game is hardly without mistakes even
for for white but it's just a very very
impressive game there's no way you can
see this game enough be left with a
warming sensation so of course white can
take the pawn but then by taking the
pawn back his pawn structure is very
gloomy
you know isolated pawn isolated pawn and
black he's just going to continue
developing so white decides to try to go
for more the heck with the pawn the
problem d3 is not going anywhere
let's try to attack the pawn on f7 and
okay Queen f6 very very reasonable
defending the pawn in a normal way he
does want to go to e 7 because he want
to put the night there especially in
view of that monster bishop on c1
visiting the a3 square so white has to
continue the initiative and he does a 5
of course it is very advisable to take
with the knight on e5 I don't I'm sure I
don't have to convince you of that that
all black needs like a hole in the head
is that the open a Fe file when the rook
is going to come from f1 to e1 and does
going to spell disaster so
Queen to g6 okay Queen a5 is another
move but queen g6 is very legitimate
okay and rook e1 if I remember correctly
in the Kasparov game somebody played
Bishop e3 I forget who it was a player
has power but that's not our game for
today anyways so Bishop a3 was tried
here he tries rook to e1 9g 7 very
reasonable and now Bishop a try so in
this position of course white is
claiming some initiative for the
sacrifice material two very agile
bishops on very important diagonal
criss-crossing f7 and a 7 and the pawn
on d3 I guess it's as good as gone at
some point is going to be captured so
black is still in no danger and he
played the move b5 that was a very very
bad man of course the fronts probably
thought himself well if I'm going to
Castle I might face an attack may be
like rook III like for example after
castles rookie 3 and Bishop takes d3
attacking the Queen and the rook might
swing later on in this direction with a
knight g5 or something he must have been
really afraid against someone at the
level of Anderson but in retrospect when
you look at it with analysis there was
not that much to fear black would be
really ok after ad councils or d5 the
position is very tenable black
definitely should not but he decided to
be aggressive counter aggressive and he
said ok fire would fire so b5 now the
idea of course if Bishop takes b5 rook
b8 and the pin is very annoying so he
simply took with the Queen decided to
play rook b8 that was the idea of the
pawn sacrifice he opened the file for
his rook and now the rock is attacking
the Queen the Queen is to go to some
place a bit clumsy a4 not not in the
center not in the middle of the game in
the arena and in this position black
played Bishop to b6 of course there were
other moves for example Bishop to b7
looks like a really appetizing move the
bishop has to be good on the long
diagonal and eventually of course it
gets there but I'm assuming that the
thought was if Bishop to b7
white is going to lift his rook again to
e3 with a double purpose of well
first regaining the pawn especially in
anticipation of at some point black
castling and the rook can always be
available for a slide along the
third-ranked black is trying to prevent
it by taking away the e3 square from
that rock okay so far reasonable Knight
to d2 not the only move but clearly an
acceptable one definitely not a terrible
one and in this position black
definitely should do something like
castles but he decided to play Bishop to
b7 and now things are becoming more and
more dangerous for him the more you
leave your King in the center the worse
off you will get 94 when you look at the
position even when you don't look for
concrete threats you can already tell
that white is enjoying the game a lot
more than black all these pieces are
working not only they are developed
because blacks are also developed but
there are in very very harmonious
attacking positions they really are
working together the queen is the one
piece that right now maybe may not be
the most impressive but all the rest are
doing something very productive
now again black needs to be a little
cautious here because with this
amassment of pieces you have to do
something and he played Queen f5 that
was in my opinion a real very suspicious
move really really a suspicious man
again casting would not have been that
bad even though Knight g5 is a bit
annoying but our Bishop takes d3 could
be annoying he probably really was
afraid of the idea of Bishop takes pawn
shifting the bishop attacking the Queen
indirectly with the knight check
threaten and then if she figured the
Queen is gonna have to travel and travel
but the Queen would could always go to
e6 and then stay safe there here here if
it always go out when the bishop moves
Queen f5 was not a good move here now it
was white to move and in this position
why decided to play the move Bishop
takes d3 which is reasonable Queen age 5
and they're really really lots of upper
lots of opportunities here in the game
he played Knight f6 Chuck okay this was
what we call it's a move for the crowd
okay if you didn't play this move funny
enough this this game may never have
made it to the ontology of
famous combinations and really amazing
games he could have played the more
prosaic Knight to g3 queen eight-six
Bishop c1
the queen is being harassed or us or us
Queen e6 Bishop c4 notice that the queen
is getting no respite and after this you
have to play Knight d5 why because queen
g6 the queen is lost Knight h4 notice
that the Queen just keeps moving and
moving now it has exactly one move
without being captured but it's still
going to be captured after here Bishop
f7 I know lateral moves sometimes are
hard to see but in this case you'll
notice that the Queen on a4 is hitting
the Queen on g4 and the queen is lost so
he would have to do something like
Knight d5 in this position after which
Knight g5 queen g4 rookie for Queen g4
was the only move to try to prevent the
obvious Bishop takes Knight because now
the Queen would take this Queen not of
course there's no Chuck but he plays
rookie 4 and black is really really
unhappy here so of course if this this
would this could have been a very boring
way to end the game and like I said it
would never you would just never make
the famous box instead he plays Knight
f6 and this move is completely spoiling
the advantage it looks like it's a
winner but it's not it really is it's
really a dubious mistake so okay of
course it's a fork of a king in Queen so
you must take and you took back for a
moment it looks really scary there's
multiple attacks on e7 and there's like
a pin here and the all the pieces are
working fantastic but so far black is
answering calmly rook g8 the best move
answering attack with an attack now the
g2 square looks very very Mull neural
and black is really doing ok white plays
again a lot of preparatory move the last
reserve is coming into action everything
else is working the rock denied the
bishops and of course he needs the other
rook on d1
important move and now black goes wrong
this is where black goes wrong he just
he looked at the position calculated saw
no immediate mate no obvious mate and
decided to go for Queen takes f3 of
course that is a bad move what should he
have done instead by the way you'll see
that it's quite hidden why this is a bad
move what should he have done instead
well for example the move Queen h3
according to analysts and I think that
engines as well would have been
completely safe for black he is
threatening mate and very importantly
the Queen Dooley is also protecting the
pawn on g7 some of you might say what is
there to protect the pawn on g7 it's not
even attacked once but if you see the
continuation the game you will
definitely understand so Queen h3 and
the game is still balanced but instead
he decides like I said to take them the
knight on f3 and thanks to this move now
the game gets its glory
now it's White's turn is about to face
checkmate in one move but this is it
shows you again that the right to move
when you have the initiative you're
calling the shots first rook takes a 7
ok I guess that this is the kind of move
that black and white should have
analyzed like every move it was in the
air there's a check the rook is
attacking a piece it looks like
something that needs to be considered
continuously alright so in this position
he took it and okay it wouldn't really
matter because if he would have moved
then that crazy rope keeps taking stuff
rook takes d7 this time and again of
course if you take I'm just gonna play
Bishop Bishop a time f5 check with
double check with the mate and if you
move let's say or can you move to if you
go let's say you move here then white
again has a brilliancy a very very
beautiful move here and that is rook to
d8 check again it's always very
impressive when you offer a piece for
free without it's a sacrifice we're not
capturing anything and even twice as
much impressive when you are on the most
defended square d8 is the
three times and somehow every capture is
just bad news let's check it out well
it's very obvious that um rook takes
that Queen all of a sudden is not
exactly safe we just take the Queen and
thank you very much
alternatively if you take with the night
I'm going to play I'm assuming its Queen
d7 Chuck and on King takes this looks
like double check only move and
checkmate and I think that the last
thing we need to check is what happened
if he takes with a king and then I think
we are going to play what are we going
to play are we going to play here Bishop
f5 check King e7 or queen takes d1 okay
what we'll try that first here we play
check check okay this is pretty simple
right
this is winning easily so alternatively
oopsie you can play a queen takes d1
check
Queen takes d1 Knight d4 pawn g3 there
is no way you can allow the rook to take
on g2 Chuck there's no way because then
f2 everything is going to be attacked so
simply calmly defending the pawn and
after rook here
the bishop saves itself Bishop f3 and
now I think Queenie won a queen do you
want what is the solution
maybe Queen d2 I think yeah so very very
fancy going back he took with the knight
on e7
in this position you simply took and
probably thought himself well okay I
accept your sacrifice I'm ready to
deliver checkmate it looks like it looks
terrible for white that looks like White
has nothing how can you possibly defend
even Bishop f1 doesn't work because we
still rook takes g2 so of course now
comes our
Thunder from you can imagine where Queen
takes d7 again a shot out of the blue
well I can tell you that King f8 Queen
takes e7 or Bishop e7 is not very
appetizing so he had to take Bishop f5
double check it looks like white is left
with almost no material however the loot
that he has is more than enough
now of course King c6
looks like maid to me so he tried here
Bishop to d7 check and it doesn't matter
if he goes to d8 or f8 is the same
punishment and mate so we saw that
understand stall was really very very
brutal very very aggressive and here he
again got himself into the anthology of
famous combinations this is one of
probably the most known games and very
common very common in in chess
combination books now we will see a game
that I will really really doubt that you
guys have seen I'll be really surprised
if you've seen it and this is a game
that he played against a guy by the name
of Jacob Rosales or something like that
yeah and this guy is not very famous to
play with the white pieces I think he
was probably a master level player or
something they played the match and the
match was very lopsided this is probably
one of the more impressive games from
that match I think you're gonna like it
so II 4v5 this time remember Anderson is
playing black f4 again in the spirit of
the of the era if it's not Bishop c4
Bishop c5 in and Evans gambit or some
other gambit then it's the King's gambit
so takes Knight f3 pawn to g5 this is by
the way a line that's be most popular
today ok it looks like a little bit of
obscure chess we are used to development
and cancelling and here there's nothing
normal about the position it's like both
both players seem to ruin their position
positionally but black is saying hey I'm
keeping the pawn and you proved that we
have something for it
so h4g 495 so far very normal Knight f6
again even you can see even games in the
in the 21st century of very top
grandmasters going like this and he
tried Bishop c4 and that is a known
mistake this is a very very bad decision
you can play for example d4 in the
spirit of the game Knight c3 is another
possibility
and then after d6 you can just take the
pawn and again it's a balanced position
but Bishop to c4 is definitely a very
bad nerve funny huh because how can a
piece a minor piece towards the center
attacking the eternal weakness on f7 how
can this be labeled a mistake well
Anderson is going to prove it and it all
starts with this move of course the only
and most aggressive way to stop the
attack on f7 so he took Bishop d6 simply
developing the knight the bishop and
attacking the knight pawn to d4
defending the knight Knight h5 white is
saying you know what forget about you
wanted to take the pawn on f4 that's
mine
there's no way I'm giving it to you now
that the g4 pawn is held by the bishop
the Queen can take of course the knight
can take but that's extremely dangerous
after Knight g3 and again in this
position white is to make decisions it's
a really wild game you have to say to
yourself what am I going to do I mean
night the night is coming to g3 I have
to do something about it and it's hard
to give a good advice but I can tell you
that what why did was not the solution
you played Bishop to b5 check he said
okay my bishop was doing nothing on c4
and now I'm charging you some sort of a
price even you're gonna move your king
and that's probably by definition is
going to be to a less safe Square or
you're gonna put a knight or a bishop on
d7 and we're gonna get to trade some
pieces which is lovely for me or in the
case of c6 I'm just going to pick up
material with material well you can
imagine what understand chose right of
course he offered material c6 very very
strong move so I took and black took
back okay white cap taking why not and
of course now the Queen is under attack
and is the discovered shack so he simply
took it took and then you tell yourself
oh maybe this was the idea maybe he
wanted to give back give give a pawn and
now play something like Bishop to d7 and
after Bishop takes a8 Queen takes a8
and for the sacrifice exchange he has to
agile bishops and the White King
position looks very precarious not
Anderson no way you just move this King
almost like a slap in the face
take my rook be my guest and by now you
think yourself okay if I don't take that
book then what do I do
I came here did all this and I'm behind
my pieces are in disarray black is gonna
play Nigeria he's gonna even play rook
to b8 save the rock so he took it and of
course this was the intention black
blade Knight G three when you first see
the game if you didn't know that the
players are very capable players one a
master and the other one being someone
who might have been one of the top and
five in the world at a time you think
that this is pot sir a versus pot sir be
right but not so you'll see that there's
a there's some logic behind this madness
now white knows that he is about to lose
his rook back in with a really bad
position to boot and he decided to play
the move rook h2 well the analysis said
what happened after King here Knight xh1
Queen takes h1 pawn to g3 King to e1
Queen e7 King to d1 Bishop to g4 check
I'm going too fast
Bishop f3 Bishop takes pawn takes rook
to g8 look at the Kings look at all the
the White Queen side they are like
spectators on the bleachers right just
doing nothing
in the meantime black just wants to play
G 2 and G 1 and the position is just
miserable after Queen G 2 Queen takes h4
all the businesses on one side all the
poor white pieces are there again this
is one of those cases that nominally
speaking the pieces exist and the rook
is worth five and the knight is worth
three and the bishop is worth three but
in actuality white is just dying here
after king e2 Queen h2 here and guess
what the H pawn is just literally going
to go to h4 and then to h3 and why can
just resign by the time he tries to get
his pieces out of jail good luck
so well very unappetizing
and therefore he played the move rook
age they're just saying okay I'm not
giving you my rock Bishop f5 again
developing in a very normal way now he
is good and ready to take that Bishop on
a e8 so the bishop moved to d5 where
else
King to g7 the rook is about to come to
a eight with great force and again when
you count the material say wait a minute
the way I'm seeing it white is da is up
a whole rook black he's down a full
block and he's not about to get made it
but his King is just beyond saving
Knight to c3 rookie a check King f2
again for a moment you think yourself I
understand right that must have been
wrong the King looks safe enough I mean
it's not the proudest piece in the world
not that the safest King we've ever seen
but he is safe just when you thought he
was safe Anderson comes up with another
monstrous move Queen b6 pinning the pawn
not a for Queen a6 and now what to do in
this position he played back Knight back
to c3 he realized that his initial
intention of playing c4 is going to be
answered by a little Queen sacrifice
Queen takes Knight on a 4 you might say
what but the answer is coming and then
after it takes rookie to here check here
checkmate again a decoy of a queen to
force checkmate okay not very pleasant
so he went back and now I'm sorry in
this position Bishop e5 again a great
teaser the bishop looks like again when
you look at this move you think yourself
there is no way that they move like this
can work how can this work not only is
he blocking his own efile but he's
giving the bishop for free well of
course there is once again a logic
behind this move it's not a gift in the
case that he takes it Queen comes to the
free diagonal
here and mate is coming only move check
and mate so the bishop is immune what
should he have done well it's tough to
suggest a good move
probably King g1 would have been the
only other move and then of course the
Queen comes back to b6 royally simply
intending to take the pawn on d4 after
the rope coming back to try to clear
some spot of escape for the king Czech
Queen here a little switch back and the
pawn on h4 looks very very delicious on
the very next move the Queen is going to
come to h4 and there's I don't see any
way to save the save from mate so again
a very very brutal display of an attack
well why tried something a little more
naive you played them of a for his
intention is to see basically is saying
well if I have to defend the pawn on d4
I'm gonna play it with Knight b5 without
it being captured so I prepare a defense
for it and white answers with Queen f1
just when he thought that everything is
cool
of course Queen b6 Knight b5 the game
goes on forever he comes up with his
crazy move Queen to f1 check again when
you look at it again you say he must
have lost his mind he has no firepower
and he's giving his Queen how is this
gonna end up and well the answer comes
with Queen f1 the only legal move Bishop
to d4 check now we see that the king is
trapped completely Bishop e3 is the only
bigger move left route cakes and there's
no way to stop making one whatever you
do in this position is going to be
checkmate in one move in the game I
think he went King here mate
well we can say one thing about Anderson
right and he was not a chicken right
definitely a very brave player giving
pieces right and left as if as if he
didn't know their value but he really
created masterpieces but you know what
they say that in chess live by the sword
die by the sword
now we're going to see an example where
the one player who is better than him is
playing him and that is Paul Morphy so
get ready to see this game it's a again
it's a miniature but it's a really
really cute one morphe is white and
again this was played in 80 this from
the match in Paris the game game two
from the match in 1858 so let's take a
look at what happened in this game efore
c5 we got to make a note when Kasparov
analyzed this game for chess base he
already stopped right here and said
think about it 1858 and Anderson is
already playing the Sicilian it's quite
impressive
because at that time nobody knew much
about the sister and everybody was
playing a 45 was like an automatic
response and he is playing something
which is relatively unconventional very
brave knight c6 here amazing how so many
years ago they played something that is
still very well known theory today takes
takes c6 time enough Sicilian is known
today because it was further developed
by Grandmaster time on of Knight b5 very
viable option Knight c3 is the other
option
pawn to d6 otherwise the knight goes to
d6 we check Bishop to f4 again a very
legitimate move you'll see it even at
top-of-the-line games of today in
contemporary games other alternatives of
course you can play c4 like Karpov so
Bishop f4 e 5 Bishop e3 so the idea was
yes the bishop lost the tempo but they
attack on d6 forced black to play the
move e5 which leaves the D pawn as a
backward pawn and the d5 square is a
very interesting outpost if you think
well that doesn't mean much just keep
seeing this game so in this position
again the normal idea is 9
six attacking the pawn on e4 white
spends one more tempo to come here and
it's well known that after a six black
is doing okay it's really it's really a
safe line black and play Bishop e6
Bishop e7 it's almost like a sveshnikov
variation and it's alright
but true to his spirit and his style he
plays the move f5 I think that several
years ago American Grand Master sha Bal
of Alexander Shabab who is again someone
who's very well known for very
sacrificial games and he doesn't mind
getting into a really bad position as
long as he can really muddy the water
and try to complicate the game for his
opponent a result of playing in many
open tournaments where you have to win a
lot I think he also played this move I
don't remember if he had success with it
but Anderson certainly did not
so more free simply plays 93 and
Anderson continues with his idea and he
plays the move f4 looks great right the
bishop seems to retreat so you think
yourself okay probably he calculate the
following continuation Bishop to d2 and
after that a six so we're looking for
example at this a 693 and then either be
five or nine up six and black is doing
quite okay the bishop on d2 is a bit
clumsy the Knights are a bit clumsy but
instead he must have been really shocked
and it's a bit surprising because
someone with his level and with his
style of play should have anticipated
the following move either he
underestimated it or he just blunted it
Knight d5 game over out of the blue
right out of the opening he is in real
trouble now of course 97 is threatened
he tried to take what else any other
move you're just gonna if you try to
save it let's say King f7 or rook b8 I
can just move my bishop and the check on
c7 is inevitable or if you moved your
king then I won't even bother because
you won't be able to cancel so blacks
position is already on the brink and
people
here night check king f7 okay now it was
more for his turn to play not the best
move okay he played Queen f3 check but
of course he should have just taken the
point is that this is kind of an in/out
visit he takes the take the knight if
black plays something like let's say 97
to try to trade nights and trap this
night then this night just comes out
he's up in exchange and there's really
not much to be afraid of life is really
fine
so but of course more fee much like
Anderson doesn't like just winning
material and winning technically he
wants a brilliancy so he played Queen to
f3 check Knight f6 Bishop c4 again a
brutal position the black King looks on
the critical list but black has some
resources as well believe me he does he
almost had them to Knight d4 super move
the best move anything passive here is
just gonna get spanked the position is
just too bad here for the black king so
he cannot afford to he needs to play
very aggressively now of course again
white has a dilemma his queen is under
attack and is about to be captured with
check
not to mention night c2 if you even
dream about taking the spawn of course
you'll get forked so Knight takes f6
check and understand here plays the only
move pawn to d5 again this you look at
the game and if you didn't know the
names of the players you plot you
thought that that might be some losers
just game played by two very random
players because it's like no value you
have to every move you have to kind of
count what what is the material
situation like right now believe it or
not well please speaking it's even
everything is the same material is just
dead livin right now so instead if you
wouldn't have played d5 if he was to
play qg6 then white has a very cute win
he will play Chuck gotta take the knight
Knight Chuck
and black has to lose its Queen because
the King is kind of running out of moves
here right after this yeah because if
you go king e7 Queen f7 looks like the
big one right just checkmate
so you would lose your queen of course
even if you win an exchange or something
the black king is just beyond hope so
what he does like we said he plays
they're very smart pawn to d5 Bishop
takes d5 check and now he thought to
himself well that variation now has a
big difference there is no pawn on d6 so
I can afford to play king g6 but he was
wrong the correct continuation was to
sacrifice the Queen now he should have
played well
King e7 was even simple sorry here here
here here of course white is still doing
okay but black is not getting made it
after here here alright maybe white his
up a pawn but with two bishops and now
of course I'm gonna save my rook may be
rook b8 the game goes on there is no
mate you know there's just not much okay
I have to say that according to Kasparov
in this position after king e7 what a
rude move the King goes right in the
middle of the board everything is
hanging after Queen h5 threaten Queen f7
he just takes check here takes okay a
bit of a mess but again no mate the
black king is not getting maiden and of
course he has the possibility of also
winning material so again a crazy crazy
game just completely crazy but poor
understand thought that he can just play
the move King g6 he thought himself what
is the difference let try to explain he
thought himself after Queen h5 Queen
takes f6 King takes f6 98 Queen takes e8
and then at the end is going to have
Bishop before Chuck let me show you
because well more free want into it half
of it takes and now came a shock if he
would have played 98 Jack Queen takes
Queen takes before it was just winning a
Queen when there was a deep on but now
of course black has Chuck followed by
rook takes Queen a very means
prize if you are the white player you
just lose but of course Morse is more
free so further and I will show you what
what happened after this he played half
takes III a very very simple move again
well we know that King safety is
everything in chess in this position not
only is white down a piece but his
knight on c7 is hanging the pawn on c2
can be captured with Chuck followed by
the rook on a1 but this glorious King on
f6 is not going to see the light of day
it's all over
so in the game he took on c2 had he
played Queen c7 to take them to
eliminate that unknowing night then
white would have played check here check
here
check check M now comes a funny move a
very calm castling long threatening the
bishop moving with mate of course the
only way to try to stop it immediately
is put the bishop on d6 and now white
answers with bishop sacrifice of his own
Bishop takes b7 followed by rook takes
d6 and Bishop takes on a 8 everything is
hanging all of a sudden it seems like
white lost all I mean black lost all his
pieces of course white is completely
winning her totally winning just a
complete crush so okay what to do
instead he took on c2 King me too
and in this position after thinking for
a very long time he resigned he found no
defense against rook F 1 check for
example let's see in a line after here
Luke F 1 check and I think that's it
right after here
doesn't look good
just winning what else he could have
tried maybe Queen c7 again but I think
that again after rook f1 King here rook
here King I guess here rook takes e7 and
just winning let's say after this here
and black loses all these pieces so
after 17 moves the great Anderson had to
capitulate so yeah what more fries maybe
a monster no question about that
okay guys those were the games for
today's games by the legend out of
Anderson and one lost by him and next
week we'll see another master of the
past famous games thank you for your
time